So we've worked with notifications and
more recently with widgets.
Both are good examples of API's
provided by the Android system
that let your app extend beyond the full
screen activity we started with.
However, this isn't limited
to just the system.
Apps can also provide API's you
can integrate into your app to
further extend your app.
A little research shows that this is
exactly how Muzei does its magic.
It extends the live wallpaper
API provided by Android.
Gives us an easy API where we only worry
about sending Muzei new wallpapers.
And it does all the work actually
displaying them to the user,
controlling things like how bright or
blurred the picture should be,
fixing those issues with readability,
we mentioned before.
And even mirroring the wallpaper over to
Android Wear devices if the user wants.
So how do we do it?
First, we'll add a gradle dependency.
Then a manifest entry for
our MuzeiArtSource.
MuzeiArtSource is an intent service,
which Muzei will connect
to get our wallpapers.
The intent filter is how Muzei knows
it can connect to our service.
We'll also include a special icon,
description and even a color to
help make sunshine feel at home.
So what happens when a user selects
our app for their wallpapers.
First, we get a call back in our
Muzei Art Source of on Enabled.
Then on Subscriber Added.
Then comes the most important one,
on Update.
This is where we will publish our
wallpaper making it available to Muzei.
Similarly, upon selecting
a different app,
we'll get an on Subscriber Removed,
and on Disabled callback.
So what would our on Update look like?
We'll do a simple query to
get the current weather.
Use a new Utility method
getImageURLForWeatherCondition
to get the appropriate wallpaper URL and
then build up an Artwork object.
In our case we'll include the imageUrl.
We'll use a description of the weather
as the title or main piece of content.
And then we'll use
the locationQuery as the byline.
Our secondary line of text.
Muzei offers the ability
to open more details.
Loading the main activity of
sunshine seems like a good way of
seeing more details to me.
We'll pass that artwork
through to publishArtwork.
Like magic, we'll see Muzei
handle all the image loading,
live wallpaper code and other work to
get our imagery on the user's wallpaper.
Neat.
While we have the option of using
Muzei's scheduleUpdate method,
we can use the same
approach as our Widget, and
use our data changed action
to trigger an update.
That way, whenever the data changes,
we'll update the wallpaper as well.
In this case, though,
we're triggering a service.
So we'll add a start service call,
to our sync adapter.
Then, our onHandleIntent,
can include a special check for
the data updated action.
And if we're enabled, and
the user who has selected us as their
background source,
we can call our own update method.